la ministre des transports de l'ethiopie
a rendu public son résumé du rapport
préliminaire de l'écrasement du vol le
t3 102 il contient peu d'informations
mais il est catégorique sur une chose
d'accord formel de procédures établies
telles cartes l'erreur de pilotage est
donc exclue après l'écrasement du vol de
laâyoune r610 en octobre dernier boeing
avait rendu public les procédures pour
désactiver son logiciel anti décrochage
en cas d'erreur de lecture des capteurs
d'incidence ce logiciel
em casse à baisse automatiquement le nez
de l'avion quand il détecte un angle
d'ascension trop vertical on sait que
les pilotes de la nr n'ont pas pu ou pas
su le désactiver mais les pilotes
détient aucune eux savaient et ils ont
désactivé mais ça n'a pas suffi une
autre panne quelque part at elle
paralysée les commandes de vol on ne
sait pas encore pas de faute de pilotage
mais alors une ou des fautes de
conception du 737 max le rapport
éthiopien met la pression sur boeing
et si oui on est un winner of the world
dont boeing doit revoir toutes les
commandes de vol de l'appareil et les
agences de sécurité aérienne doivent
ensuite les certifier pas seulement la
paix phares américaines qui est sous
enquête du congrès au du fbi mais aussi
les agences de tous les pays où voler
des 737 max ou l'europe et la chine et
le canada
alors pour quand la reprise des vols ça
va être seulement qu'à tout le monde
les actuels le canada en premier que
d'abord concombres à ce qui s'est passé
et qu'on a trouvé une solution qui est
saint pourçain tiers ce sera long il
faudra avoir avant tout les rapports
finaux des deux écrasement celui d'être
championne pourrait n'être près que dans
un an
jean michel leprince radio-canada à
montréal